he's the coach of Clemson football he's
Dabo Swinney back here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you coach good what's going
on your pie week how do you spend a bye
week well we had we had a kind of full
week of practice Monday Tuesday where's
the Thursday actually Tuesday we did
some community service here in our
community as team and then we broke
practice last night and everybody's
actually off Friday Saturday Sunday so a
good little break for everyone and I've
been just kind of catching up on some
stuff today going to high school
football tonight
okay watch my fifth grader play and hey
and just chill out tomorrow watching
college football and be ready to go on
Monday well you're not a helicopter dad
are you what type of dad are you of
would your your kid plane oh oh no man
I'm gonna get a diet coke and some
popcorn and a slim jim sickle and sit in
the stands and watch the game that is
what I am I just oh I had all these
school colors and go blend in hold on a
second is that really what you're gonna
get a slim jim in a pickle is that
really there's that part of you lately
that's my go-to every day every week
slim jim in a pickle I didn't I did not
I would not have ever ever guessed that
okay so that's that's what you're doing
tonight now in terms of what happened
last week obviously you want to win a
football game which you were able to do
do you as a coach say good I'm glad that
my team got pushed to the limit I'm glad
that a lot of these kids that might be
reading about their their rankin that
this happened do you do you take that
view of it well I mean I prefer to beat
everybody and just relax in the fourth
quarter I'd be great but that's just not
reality you know everybody has good
players and good coaches and everybody
wants to win and you know we were
certainly willing to play and Clemson
everybody wants to you're gonna get
everybody's best but I but what I am
glad about is I saw us handles and
diversity you know we played four games
I really thought we would houses thirsty
I just thought it'd been it in it at
Syracuse early in the season we got 80
freshmen and sophomores but we really
haven't had a fourth quarter where
there's been really any drama
and all Virginia's pretty much been over
this fourth quarter so it was good to
see and a positive to see our team have
to respond in the fourth so I think
that's good and I hadn't seen treble
arcs has not had a game he's played 20
games in his constant career and he is
not had a game where he's had any
adversity in the quarter at all
because you know he only played to see
plays he gets a.m. last year and then
and then the other game Syracuse last
year he he was playing well and he got
hurt after about a quart and a half so
he's not had a fourth-quarter where he's
had to make big plays to win the game
and so I it was from that standpoint I
think it's a real positive there's good
and bad and everything so there was good
there the bad is is we made a lot of
mistakes had a lot of felonies you turn
the ball over and we were fortunate to
win the game but again not just to win
and I think it's a it's great to see
that those intangibles in our team how
that you have to have to be a really
good football team how would you rate
Trevor Lawrence's development this year
in comparison to last coach oh great I
mean he's a much smarter quarterback
he's a great leader this time last year
he was just you know trying to find a
you know go win the job and had just won
the job about this time last year and
yeah it just is just bigger stronger
smarter he is a true leader it's a very
natural thing for him has a great
understanding of what we're doing and
has done well I mean again he hasn't
played really you know they didn't play
most of the game against Georgia Tech we
came out against Syracuse only played
about a quarter and a half against
Charlotte and in Texas A&M we really put
chase price and for the fourth quarter
and controlled the game so I think
you've done well he's made a couple
mistakes certainly he's had a couple of
mental mental bucks and things like that
but they made some big-time play and the
other thing the area we wanted him to
prove the most and was making some plays
with his legs and
and really he has done a great job from
that standpoint he's made some big time
scrambles with his Linux pure runs with
his legs but also he's extended a bunch
of plays that have led to big plays
where he's you know extended the plates
we touch down past or extended to play
and make a you know a big big throw off
a scramble so I've been I've been proud
of him and definitely room to improve as
he goes forward but especially against
North Carolina said I learned something
about it because in my experience in 20
games I've never seen him with a game on
the line a fourth quarter and he was
awesome it was awesome down the stretch
his leadership his toughness his grit
his will to win was good to see that in
that moment
Clemson head coach two-time national
champion head coach Dabo Swinney here on
the Rich Eisen show coach I've had a
bunch of players on this week on this
subject from current players like
Richard Sherman earlier this hour Chris
Webber formerly of Michigan he was in
studio yesterday talking about the
California fair pay to play act we're
starting in 2023 collegiate athletes
will be allowed to hire an agent to make
money off their name likeness and image
players are essentially lockstep and
saying it's way overdue thank goodness
for that you're my first coach I've had
on since this and I wonder what your
thoughts are on the subject right now on
me I think that I think potentially
there could be a lot of positives that
come from it you know and it could it
just depends on how it all shakes out
there's gonna be a lot of litigation a
lot of back-and-forth from a lot people
a lot more smarter than me between now
and 2020 three but it could it could
spur some some positive change that that
may further you know the the the the
scholarship is has come a long way you
know there's been a lot of great changes
and a lot of people don't talk about or
even realize be honest with you over the
last five years ten years especially the
last you know five years and I think
it's great but there's still more room
for improvement you know my
modernization of the collegiate model if
you will and so from that standpoint it
could be a lot of positives come from it
was have to see I don't know all the
details I would just say but just on the
surface just as it is like sitting like
day
right now it's probably not good for
college athletics as a whole probably
good for a few but not good for college
athletics as a whole but it's it's a
long way away from I think where it's
going to be but the positive is it might
spur some real you know positive changes
and my 15 years is I've always just I
value the collegiate experience value
education and I just AM always I'm
against professionalizing college
athletics I'm very very passionate about
that and that doesn't mean that there's
not lots of room for improvement and
things to modernize things that have
been done but I just think I just think
it should be tied to education in the
collegiate model so we'll see I mean I
don't really know where it all is going
to go I think there's a lot of things
that will shake out between now and
whenever it goes into effect and and
hopefully it will be positive and not
negative but certainly worth the
conversation yeah I know in terms of the
conversation it's just the the general
sense is that if let's say one of your
players I could could make a t-shirt
based off of his likeness or one of your
players could hold a clinic or one of
your players could make some extra
scratch by making an appearance locally
in in on campus that that's something
that would be fine is that something
that you would be fine with as a coach
or boosters could get involved and and
and you know so there's just there's
just too many unknowns right now with no
parameters and I think that there has to
be some parameters I think you know from
a collegiate model standpoint now from a
professional model no okay have at it
you know but it's just a matter of you
know there's just a lot of answers a lot
of things I think have to be vetted out
from consequences unintended
consequences you know things like that
so it's really for me you know just I
think it's we just got to sit back and
we gotta let all the people who are
going to be making these decisions and
sort it out figure all these things out
and go from there Dabo Swinney here on
the Rich Eisen showing
minutes I have left with you the
quarterback at Alabama when you coached
the wide receivers and tight ends is
actually gonna be on Monday Night
Football on the sidelines of the the
Cleveland Browns against Richard Sherman
coordinating the offense essentially to
try and score points on Richard Sherman
and Freddie kitchens is there a good
Freddie kitchen story that you knew at
the time that he was going to be head
coaching material devil I can't really
say that I just thought when he was when
I was there as a coach when I was
coaching receivers he was the he was our
quarterback right so it obviously spent
a lot of time was were part of the crew
process and came afraid it was a really
good player and but he he was never real
committed to his diet and takes care of
himself so he was always one of the one
of the one of the biggest quarterbacks
we had ever been around but he was
really talented him to play he was a
smart player and a lotta guts the
instincts you know I didn't know if he
was that he would end up going into
coaching at the time but we came back we
had to beat Auburn in 1996 it was about
a I don't know maybe two minutes or a
little less something like that I don't
think we had any timeouts I remember
correctly and we got to go to distance
to beat Auburn and his coach tones last
game you know he's retiring after the
game players don't know that us coaches
knew that and just remember being up in
the in the box on the headset woody
micawber he was off its coordinator he's
like hey we're gonna put Freddie in the
shotgun and we're going what you know
cause because we never we'd you know at
that sweet we were not we were an
affirmation team there been shots sure
and Woody's over and and our well coach
is going shotgun have you lost your mind
what he's like hey we got no chance we
got no time we got it we got it back
there where we can see and so it was it
was there literally were drawing up
plays on the sidelines of what we're
gonna do in the shotgun and Freddie
takes us right down the field literally
takes us right down the field and we win
the game and hits Dennis riddle a little
angle route to win the game it was a
epic moment
so I've seen him under pressure and you
know I've just I've always had a lot of
respect for him he's a very transparent
guy and he's worked his butt off to get
to where he is and got a lot of spike to
him so he'll he'll uh he'll do a good
job just excited for his opportunity and
I think he and paper based fielder
they'll be there will be a good tandem
and they'll get this thing going and be
successful there in Cleveland that's
what I think coach thanks for the time
appreciate it enjoy the rest of your bye
week your pickle and your slim jim and
your coke or you die coke and uh and the
Friday Night Lights tonight enjoy it
right back at you that's Dabo Swinney
head coach for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR Live or download
the Rich Eisen show app